How are you doing?
Someone is asking me,
you said some place that you felt like you were at times dancing on broken
glass.
No,
I think I said that I was,
I always felt like I was dancing on broken glass.
Are you getting enough rest and R.
And R is the food sensitivity getting worked out?
I think maybe the food sensitivity thing is getting worked out.
I think it's at the basis of this depression that's been played in my family for
generations,
but I haven't figured out exactly what it is.
Yeah.
Town.
I'm working very hard on that with my daughter who also seems to have the same
problem and it,
it is absolutely brutal.
It's absolutely brutal.
So,
um,
am I getting enough rest?
And R.
And R,
that's hard to say because with the responses that I'd been having that have
knocked my health back,
it's,
it's hard to discriminate between rest and our and our,
the lack of that and just getting walloped by,
by eating what appears to be the wrong thing.
So it's so funny because,
you know,
for years I was very skeptical of anyone who was concerned about,
gluten sensitivity and that sort of thing.
But I sure learned that that was,
um,
arrogant.
So,
yeah.
Well,
I've found many times in my life that you have to be aware of what you are
judgmental about because many things come back to haunt you.